For more than 100 years, this picture has been holding a secret.
On the back of Van Gogh's "Head of a Peasant Woman"...
...is a previously unseen work by the artist.
The ghostly image was revealed...
...as experts carried out an x-ray on the painting.
Oh, it was a complete shock,...
...and I have to say, pretty much instant recognition...
...and we thought, my goodness, there he is.
We have his hat and his beard, signature neckerchief around his neck...
...and it just struck us immediately that it was a self-portrait.
As a poor artist, Van Gogh used both sides of the canvas to save money,...
...but the self-portrait side is covered in cardboard and glue.
Experts hope they can safely remove the material from this valuable piece.